this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you so much to you it is such a
privilege and pleasure to be here and
thank you all for making this time in
your busy schedules and first and
foremost I have some questions for you
how many of you like to grow things how
many of you have saved seed before how
many of you have developed brand new
varieties of vegetables yes how many of
you know the story of David and Goliath
and how many of you woke up this morning
put on clothes I need something for
breakfast
so good news is we have a lot in common
and and here's the thing you all play a
larger role in our food system in our
seed system today and the world that
we're building for our
great-great-grandchildren as well
perhaps more than you realize and even
if you've never developed a brand new
variety of vegetable if you've saved the
seeds of vegetables and flowers of herbs
you've made subtle shifts in that
variety and that's really all that a
plant breeder is doing - no offense
Michael maybe there's some more
methodology and there are certainly lots
of intention but next now you know next
time someone asks you if did that you've
developed new varieties that have
forever changed the genetics available
its people on this planet if you have
save seeds confidently raise your hands
and even if you've never sown a seed in
your life every day you eat and every
day you put on clothing and so every day
you are determining the plants that are
being bred by those professional plant
breeders all around the country and all
around the world so even if you never
sow a seed your life every day impacts
the seeds being bred and sewn around the
world that are changing the world for
our grandchildren and David and Goliath
is a story that I thought I knew and it
turns out I didn't know it so part of my
story today is sharing with you one of
my favorite stories retold
my name is Cara Petra Paige man and I
grew up here in the Finger Lakes saving
seed I really like to eat and that is
the core of my passion my motivation
that brings me here today and to my
fields every day that I'm so fortunate
in 2012 I started a seed company with my
beloved partner Matthew Goldfarb and
we're really excited to grow seeds
organic seeds that are originally
adapted for this place I've traveled all
around the world I love plants and I
love that I can see that even between
here in Ithaca there are different kinds
of Oaks than there are in Naples on my
farm
to say nothing of the Oaks that are in
Oregon to say nothing of the Oaks that
are Australia and I really believe that
seed can be that resilient as well if we
choose to select it so so without
further ado I left my clicker over
yonder
so I'd like to start with what is a seed
and a seed I'm doing a lot of moving
around today a seed is a living
breathing being just like you and I and
this particular seed is a hub in ishani
skunk bean the Haudenosaunee people does
anyone recognize that name yes the
Iroquois people Iroquois vaguely sounds
French and indeed Iroquois was the
French derogatory term for indigenous
people in this bean has been grown in
the valley where I grew this bean for
over a thousand years and without
question it is the most disease
resistant it's the quickest maturing and
we harvest twice the yield of any other
cold dry bean I've ever grown which
perhaps isn't saying that much because
I'm a little girl and I don't have an
extensive trialing system but I've grown
a lot of dry beans in my day and this
being friends I have to imagine that
there's something to the fact that
it's been growing in our soils been
adapting with our climate and adapting
with our ancestors as all of these
variables have changed over time this is
such a profoundly regionally adapted
variety and it sends shivers down my
spine in the same way that we have
ancestors and that we may become
ancestors these seeds made to become
ancestors as all of the ancestors
countless that have come before them
part one the magic of seeds and seeds
are domesticated plants right
I've been around we've been
domesticating plants give or take ten
thousand years and I love every time I
see the image of teosinte it sends
shivers down my spine again because I
would have just mowed it if it was in my
lawn ancestors that knew nothing about
DNA have been selecting this grass for
thousands of years and now it's grown
over millions of acres on every
continent except Antarctica and feeds
outrageous percentage of our global
population every day and I have to
imagine that those same people in the
Andes thousands of years ago if I'd
asked them have you ever developed a
brand-new variety of vegetable they
probably would have not raised their
hands as well but here we are probably
all of us in this room today I've
already eaten corn at some point in the
last day if not week multiple times
those ancestors have impacted our lives
in an fab unfappable ways and to a new
save seeds this is the impact that you
may have on countless generations as
well and we reap what we sow I love does
anyone recognize what the seed head
might be PS by the way
it is carrot yes and so same genus
species as Queen Anne's lace which is
the reason we put it in isolation cages
at our farm and then still are nervous
but we probably so in that these seeds
that we can save and pass on generation
after generation we've lost over 80
percent of the genetic diversity that
we've cultivated as a species in the
last ten thousand years and I don't the
percentage is always changing and I
can't quite keep up with it but
something around sixty percent of all
the seeds all the genetic diversity on
this planet is controlled by three and
now quickly to companies it's ludicrous
this precipice that we find ourselves on
as seed has gone from this Commons this
I can't imagine selling new water or
selling you the hair that you're
breathing and I can't quite imagine
selling you the seed packet in fact I'm
not selling you the seeds I'm selling
you a really beautiful packet with some
nice information and a website where you
can learn how to grow them really well
this is what I tell myself anyway there
happens to be seeds inside too but as
seed has moved from Commons to a
commodity and our food system has become
increasingly globalized our seed system
has dramatically changed as well and one
day I was sharing this extraordinary
darkness that I feel around our food
system in our seed system with my dear
friend Bill mcdorman and perhaps some of
you know Bill mcdorman here's this
crafty wizard poet of a seed saver and
he as I'm telling him this distr he
shared with me this quote which I'm
happy to share with you before we delve
into some other stories so he smiled at
me as I'm like on the verge of tears
reaching for my hanky and as I'm sharing
with him the sadness that I feel and he
said well Patrick let me tell you you
forgot you have forgotten something
because in a single generation we have
lost untold wisdom around our genetic
heritage but you've forgotten that there
is
infinite potential and a handful of
seeds because each seed is infinitely
replicable incredibly adaptable and
they're everywhere so we'll break that
down for 45 seconds each seed is
infinitely reputable I love that that
seed that I'm passing around that have
been a Shawnee skunk bean I planted one
of those the first week in June from
that single seed I'll harvest thousands
probably at least a thousand if not two
thousand seeds from a single plant by
fall with things like amaranth there
will be tens of thousands of seeds from
that one single seed and I definitely am
focused on plants I'm not a
mathematician but if I have one thing
that can make ten thousand things and
each of those ten thousand things can
make another ten thousand things all of
a sudden I hope that you're hungry and I
hope that you have friends and I hope
that you also see that this is a reason
to have hope for the world and you see
it as incredibly adaptable this is a
photograph of kale overwintering on our
farm
and every year we overwinter lots of
things on our farm and other
collaborator farmers and here in the
Finger Lakes and plants can adapt to
whatever our imaginations might contrive
whether it's shipping tomatoes from San
Diego to Maine in February or asking
lettuce to overwinter uncovered in the
Finger Lakes anything is possible our
imagination is the limit and they're
everywhere I love remembering that even
if we lose 100 percent of the debt of
the genetic diversity that we've
cultivated as a species for ten thousand
years we live on the greenest planet
that I've ever seen
and we can start again and
I also have to mention in such astute
community that there's probably way more
spores in this picture than seeds I
think you get the idea so I'd love to
share this little sentiment before I
move on this is poncho and Davi by the
way my are little dogs and Davi is named
for David and Goliath which I'm excited
to share with you in a little bit but I
don't people ask me all the time why I
love saving seeds and why it's important
and I really think it's about well
building community and eating good food
but selecting seeds not just saving
seeds I'm interested in those lettuce
not that bold first and not the dye over
the winter but the ones that vote last I
had survived the winter and with those
seeds I took them in the ground and put
tuck them in packets and I'd love for
you all to take a pack at home there's a
good number of packets in there I hope
you all take them home and know that if
you'd like to keep in touch you can also
sign up on our email sheet as well we
have a monthly organic gardening
newsletter that's very entertaining as
well as informative from time to time
and oh yeah because so selecting seed is
important because oh yeah you might be
interested in a flavor or a disease
resistance or yield there's a lot of
really valid interests but you can
select your seeds for and I'd love to I
remind myself all the time that I do
this joyfully but there may be a time
that we do this out of necessity and
this time might in fact be now my dear
friends
Danvers voix up in Montreal has an
organic seed farm and three years ago
when he was starting his greenhouses he
was paddling through his greenhouses as
we were starting ours here in the Finger
Lakes and this was a hundred year flood
of the st. Lawrence and this was the
third hundred year flood in five years
so it's a very humbling reminder for me
that if I that I want to do this works
joyfully first and foremost but that out
of necessity our climates are changing
our markets are shifting as well and if
decentralization is becoming a necessity
that needs to start at the genetic level
so David and Goliath first let me
introduce my partner Matthew both I'm
spreading cover crop seed and so David
and Goliath is a story that I thought I
knew all about I've always been rooting
for the underdog
and I always thought that the improbable
was probably possible but it wasn't
until a few years ago and Malcolm
Gladwell wrote a book about David and
Goliath that I realized that oh I didn't
know this story in any way and it has
been a huge inspiration for me this
retelling of David and Goliath in
starting a seed company here in the
Northeast
because PS by the way you don't grow
seed here in the northeast Petra I spent
years growing seed where seed has grown
in the world in the Pacific Northwest
where it's dry it doesn't rain from the
beginning of May till the end of
September and the sea there's all these
great reasons why you don't grow seed in
the northeast so petrol why are you
starting a seed company in the right
least let me tell you this story about
David and Goliath so 3,000 years ago
the Philistines and the Israelites were
having a disagreement as they had had
before and they had had again but this
was one in a long line and in ancient
warfare there was this thing single
combat which was really convenient
because if you have two armies and they
go at each other a lot of life can be
lost but if you choose your one single
warrior and from one side and the other
side chooses their one single warrior
maybe we can maybe we can be a tiny bit
more civilized
so the Philistines sent down this
massive warrior their finest warrior and
he's literally a giant and he's covered
in head to toe with gleaming armor and
he has not only a sword he's brandishing
a javelin and a spear and he's pretty
formidable he is the spectre of
dominance and the Israelites are little
quaking in their boots and King Saul is
looking through his army and trying to
decide who could he possibly send to
defeat this undefeatable giant
the Giants name by the way was Goliath
and no one's stepping forward King Saul
doesn't want to have anybody four and
this little Shepherd steps up his name
happens to be David and the Shepherd
says well you know I've been fending off
lions and wolves and my flock for years
and I think I got this and King Saul
says thanks I am gonna laugh at you
right here in the Bible I'm laughing at
you and and he goes to take off his
armor the king of the Israelites takes
off his own armor to send the shepherd
boy to battle with and David says no I
really I don't need these things but I
do need some stones so he leans down and
he brings five stones from the valley
floor with him and he goes to meet
Goliath and here's the thing slingers
were a thing 3,000 years ago and like
slingshots our children's toys but these
people could swing stones like 45
millimeter handgun style with incredible
accuracy and I think you can see where
this story is going David just walks up
to this giant far enough away so that
Goliath has no chance to use his
well-honed beautiful gleaming tools
weapons against him and he just shoots a
stone right here
and Goliath is down on the ground waning
consciousness David walks up takes
goliaths own sword and locks off his
head and why we all know a different
story why we all think it was surprising
that David one is a different story but
a piece today that I want to share with
you all that I love remembering because
I forget all the time is that advantages
are not always advantages and
disadvantages are not always
disadvantages and when the underdog
knows the tools in his pocket when the
underdog is on his own turf when he's
confident and when he refuses to play by
the rules of the dominant paradigm the
underdog wins every time
Malcolm Gladwell's book beautifully
portrays this and yeah Goliath didn't
have a chance so how does this relate to
the seed system we have the Goliath of
this industrial global economy feed seed
food system and it's pretty formidable
the branding we can't touch it people
buy things buy their products just
because on the reputation and they've
been around for so long and these
international markets they're so
significant and the profit centers that
they have nailed oh my goodness it's
really it's incredibly challenging to
see how we can possibly begin to create
a different paradigm and take down this
incredible Goliath of a food system that
is serving some people but who is really
being served by this food system and
then we have David this is my little
friend in a field of kale and intruments
burg and surrounded by four acres of
kale that and so here's the thing about
seed in the Northeast
we're on our own turf we're saving seeds
Institute in place no one is doing this
work unless we do this work and we don't
have to play by the same game we can
make up our own rules we can make up our
own vision of branding our own vision of
all of these tools that have and we
don't have to throw the baby out with
the bathwater there's a lot of babies
and there's a lot of bathwater but
another thing that is really critical is
David knew how to wield his tools well
and yes we might have some significant
constraints here in the Northeast for
creating quality seed but we have some
great tools whether it's timing just
when do you plant things when you
harvest things whether it's using things
like root cellars or high tunnels
leveraging other kinds of resources in
our communities and just looking at it
not only as what can we do on our farm
but how can we collaborate with other
farmers with other with our local
universities with whether it's you know
food banks there are so many tools that
we have in our toolbox and add and and
the creative piece of thinking outside
the box we have so many reasons why
Sita's yes there are certainly
constraints to growing economic to
competing at global economic scale
growing seed here in the Northeast but
I'm incredibly excited to be constantly
learning more every day and finding more
people excited to do this work and
here's the other thing too about David
and Goliath and you and I and the world
that were living in and are saving for
our grandchildren Goliath was chosen by
the Philistines he I don't know that
Goliath personally but I suspect he was
this warrior that had been
trained and groomed as this warrior from
inside for years and years and years and
he had all of these resources to buffer
him from the world around him where
David was in fact not selected by King
Saul King Saul laughed at him he chose
himself and he stood up and said I can
make a difference and let me give it a
try and so the thing is who is the King
now that's making this no industrialized
global food system Goliath
I think I'm part of it I think we all
are in the ways that we spend money and
the ways we spend our time even if we
don't overtly want to be supporting
these systems we all in little ways and
an often not little ways are part of
what is perpetuating this paradigm and
so that means we all can be David and we
all are
David should we choose to stand up and
do what we love to wield our tool as
well and to have skin in the game so yes
this is that same field of kale a month
later with Sandy and that is that same
little girl's hands going through 450
pounds of kale seed a few days after
that and now I'd like to share some
stories of different collaborations here
in the Finger Lakes that I'm really
excited about because seed in the
Northeast doesn't isn't just seed in the
Northeast it is engaging all of these
different stakeholders and the food
system and well beyond and I don't think
I have put in a big enough bug yet so
I'm going to cut myself off you're at
one of the most amazing universities on
the planet and you have a public plant
breeding program
has changed my life profoundly and has
changed this world profoundly in the
last 150 years and I'm so thrilled that
you all are a part of this wonderful
institution and have never underestimate
the David's that you already are in
creating this new world and a special
hats off to Michael is Erick
I am at your service and the same is
true for you all as well so this is a
little story about a purple cone headed
cabbage that is an heirloom variety that
Robin at Blue Heron farm and Lodi
absolutely loved and she and Lou grew
this cabbage for almost 30 years and
they personally witnessed the
degradation of this fantastic variety
from you know it has it's a beautiful
cone head dense super tender incredibly
sweet and flavorful and when we first
met them four years ago less than 10
percent of the heads were still conical
and you can see some of them were these
tiny little heads on these great big
plants and some were just regular you
know round heads and some were very
loose heads where others were dense very
few of them were actually cone headed
and actually dense and nice compact
plants and they grow but they continued
to grow it out several thousand plants
just because they loved them and they
could market them regardless and the
five eight percent that was actually
doing what they wanted to that was just
the cream on top so we went in and put
in lots of flags and we actually saved
saved plants from that first generation
there were 55 plants out of almost 2000
that actually had all of the qualities
that we were looking for and in that and
we they were able to actually cut off
the heads market the heads so they
didn't have any losses a market
gardener growing this crop and then we
lifted the roots and stems and all
brought them to our root cellar and
planted them out the following spring
and saved the seed and lo and behold
that next generation it was around 65 70
percent we're good heads and that next
generation is now being germination
tested as we speak so we'll see what it
looks like now but this is a great
example of how you know these amazing
market farmers market growers yes I
would love to have an R&D department and
have more extensive trialing at fruition
seeds but in lieu of that you we have so
many phenomenal farmers here in the
Finger Lakes that have extraordinary
observations that they've made over
decades and sometimes generations and
collaborating with them has been such a
privilege and another marvelous
land-grant University University of
Wisconsin Madison has the open-source
seed initiative and we're really excited
to collaborate with Erwin and Claire and
they have and as well as Nathaniel
Thompson at remembrance farm and so
selecting something that is a bolero the
next generation that is actually a
certified organic variety and is going
to be an Okie and I'm looking at the
time and want to share all these other
little stories and so I don't want to go
in too deeply but we can talk about
these things in a few minutes if you
would like but know that there's lots of
amazing ways that universities and
farmers and lots of other players and
the food system game are playing
together and the final piece that I
wanted to share is this lovely little
Cuza style summer squash that's very
delicious blah blah blah the exciting
part that I want to share with you is
that we've created dozens and dozens and
dozens of pounds of seed they have no
in a seed packet no place going into the
next generation so generally in new
variety development there's just a lot a
lot of byproducts whether it's delicious
food or seed that in fact has enormous
nutritive potential as well and so in
the process of creating a brand new open
pollinated varieties from and from an f1
we have collaborated with Stony Brook in
Geneva and they are this might have any
of you heard of them or tasted they're
good things I'm so glad they are so
outrageous Lee Devine and they so
they're toasting these seeds they are
pressing them for oil and then marvelous
and visionary chefs are putting them on
their table so taking this waste stream
and turning it into a revenue stream
that is not only a revenue stream but
it's really genuinely feeding people and
nourishing people has been one of my
favorite little nuances of some of our
collaborations as well I also wanted to
share this quick little story we often
grow lots of winter squash and sometimes
it's a lot of winter squash first and
when I go when I do things I tend to
really do things Oh
for better and for worse our first year
we do 7,000 pounds of winter squash and
what do you do with 7,000 pounds of
winter squash when you just need the
certified organic seed inside so we
collaborated with food link up in
Rochester and they drove a tractor
trailer down to our farm in Naples and
brought all of this various and sundry
deliciousness up to their
state-of-the-art kitchen in Rochester
and we developed this whole protocol
with them so they saved the seed right
on-site and gave us back 80 pounds of
seed and they kept the rest of the
winter squash and food link
linked up in Rochester they're a
phenomenal they serve ten counties and
their if make a model food bank for the
country and for the world and I'm going
to so piecework is a marvelous pepper
that is a project that was a farmer led
breeding development project but Cornell
very much first facilitated it back in
the day and there are so many other
things I wanted to share about this but
I am NOT going to so leave this as a as
an earmark and perhaps we can pick up
this conversation at another time
because I'd like to finish with this
slide three years ago I was invited to
save seed in the Dominican Republic and
here's the thing I've taken for granted
my entire life that I have access to
seeds so any kind of seed that I could
possibly want to grow whether they're
organic or not whether they're heirloom
whether f-1 any kind of see in the world
I have access to in the Dominican
Republic
Syngenta owns the rights exclusively to
import seed and sell seed and so anytime
you want to buy a seed in the dr you're
buying any one of that one variety
that's available from this one company
and they're ludicrously expensive and
it's really exciting to me that they are
saving seeds and sharing seeds and
building this incredible seed system
that it's not illegal for them to save
seed and it's not even illegal for them
to sell the see that they grow they just
can't import it and then sell it
which brings me to the thought that you
have seed packets in your hands I'm so
grateful you're going home with some of
my little babies and people ask me if I
have children I say yes I've
great-great-great-grandchildren effect
and you can eat them and I'm so glad
you're bringing some of them home it
makes me so happy and here's the thing
though it's an act of faith to plant a
seed and it's an act of faith to buy a
seed packet as well how many of you have
planted something and it's not actually
what it was in the seed packet it
happens all the time and fruition seeds
is part of that lovely legacy I'm sure
so it's an active faith you're just
going on faith that whatever it says on
the seed packet is what you're planting
and what are the questions that you're
asking your seed companies what are the
seed what are the questions you're
asking yourself what is the world that
you're wanting just to grow and build
for your great-great-grandchildren and
as are your seed companies actually
living into those values they could be
they may not be and the more questions
you ask the more opportunities it gives
the Davids of the world to be to do the
work and I'm really thrilled to be here
and I've listened to myself talk way too
much I'm clearly capable of monologues
but I'm really excited to have a
dialogue with you all now and so please
by all means keep in touch you'll find
all of our contact info on that seed
packet you can follow us on Instagram
and Facebook and I hope that you all
come to visit our farm in Naples as well
we're an hour and a half west but I'd
love to know if there's anything on your
mind
Geneva do you have any questions verse
[Laughter]
[Music]
so thank you for your wonderful you're
so welcome thank you for joining us we
always hear that again that you can't
grow seeds great question Steve's
question was how how do we produce
healthy disease-free seed in the
Northeast and the answer is many folds
they're certainly the answer of just
don't grow spinach here there are
certain things that I humbly have
learned that there's just a reason that
they're not grown here but the vast
majority of crops I really believe that
we can grow here and whether it's
growing things in high tunnels or just
shifting the seasonal little planting
planting schedules a little differently
or things like hot water baths you know
with tomatoes early blight is seed born
but we hot water baths any of our tomato
seed that has that has gone come from
early blight plants and then certainly I
have there are so many things that you
know that I don't know and that's where
it takes a village and having resources
like Chris smart here at Cornell I am a
little embarrassed how often I email
Chris Martin he's amazing and I don't
pretend to have all the answers and as
soon as I suspect that there's as soon
as there's something I don't know I okay
who do I know that might have some
insight so whether it's Chris smart here
at Cornell or sending photos to John
navazio you know lots of people have
lots of great insight but I'm been
really fortunate at fruition to not have
significant
significant disease issues which I
wonder too is partially a scale thing if
you're growing if you're growing acres
and acres of acres hundreds of acres of
X and you have limited genetic diversity
especially if you're you know perhaps
creating an hybrid with two very inbred
parent lions like there might be some
there might be some susceptibility that
you may not have in a smaller more
diverse context but then on the other
side of the coin that smaller more
diverse context opens you up to further
disease issues potentially as well so
it's a great question and we've been
really we've been really fortunate slash
have learned a lot about what to grow
what not to grow and when we do have
disease how to identify it and what to
do next son can you tell that story oh
I'd love to
Michael Mazurek is the beginning of many
of our stories and when we started
fruition seeds and met Michael he was
like hey you guys want some watermelon
and we like oh we love some watermelon
so he gives us 16 different packets that
are all different lines from this
initial cross they were the f3
generation and it was really fun to grow
watermelon I had never seen the
diversity potential in watermelon like I
never realized that you could have
really sweet watermelon that doesn't
taste like watermelon and then you can
have watermelon that tastes so much like
watermelon but isn't even sweet and
everywhere in between and you know super
thick rinds and some have huge seeds in
some of small seeds and some are more
fibrous and some of course mature
earlier than others and yeah some of
them have more so I was really fun to
see all of that diversity in those
initial parent lines and then we've just
been playing with them ever since very
just phenotypic Lee saying wow I think
you're beautiful and delicious and oh
you're productive and early maturing
and we're gonna save your seat and so we
we had a number of different lines that
we've just been chasing for the last for
the last handful of years and this last
year we we've been kind of eyeing these
two as our up-and-coming new varieties
and we decided to call it
August ambrosia is a variety we're
releasing this next year it's from that
initial cross that Michael made and it's
between 3/4 and like 6 7 pounds this is
the small ovular beautiful it has a
color a skin coloration I've never seen
before it's like lime green with the
silver lattice over it and it's very
early even in this season we were eating
watermelon the first week in September
pardon me in August which kind of blew
my mind last year I would have been like
yeah here's show off but you had the
year to do it in but this year I'm
genuinely bowled over that there was a
watermelon that we were eating the first
week in August and it has a nice thin
rind
the seeds are really small and are
delightful to crunch on and so we're
really and we had a wonderful party we
have lots of wonderful parties by the
way because if we have all this
watermelon and we just need the seeds I
hope you come enjoy our byproduct with
us I just eat watermelon all day that
was about a month ago
and so we had a couple hundred people
come to the farm and wander around
spitting watermelon seeds and our
dahlias and we asked everybody to name
it as well which was incredibly fun and
the grand prize was you named a
watermelon and we got all these
wonderful submissions and the one that
the one that we liked there was one that
was August and I actually forget what
the second word was and I was like
August I like where you're going with
this and one of our we have five farms
and one of our five farms we call
ambrosia from which is another wonderful
story
but it's been one of our isolations for
this watermelon for for the last three
years so we decided to call it August
ambrosia and I don't know what else you
have to say except that you'll find it
at at fruition seeds calm as well as at
green star you'll find our seeds and
that green tree at home green home and
at the AG way we'll probably have our
seeds this next year as well and you'll
can find August and brojo as well as
lots of other great Cornell varieties
like honey nut squashes haba nada and
6sp animun we and the silver slicer
cucumber I can't get enough of them so
fruition seeds offers a lot of marvelous
Cornell varieties and it's a privilege
to have a local land-grant university
dedicated to public plant breeding right
in our backyard and to play this tiny
tiny role in giving access to people to
these amazing genetics thank you done
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu